[Música]
y saludamos a nuestra enviada especial
natalia cabrera a esta novena cumbre de
las américas que se celebra en esa
ciudad estadounidense en el estado de
california natalia la saludo muy buena
mañana de jueves vamos a hablar entonces
primeramente del anuncio que hizo el
presidente de eeuu joe biden en materia
de migración en este discurso de
apertura ya formalmente de esta cumbre
natalia
hola raúl buenos días desde los ángeles
efectivamente como lo mencionaba el
presidente estadounidense yo bailé ni
hizo grandes anuncios en la sesión
inaugural de esta plenaria de jefes de
estado en el teatro microsoft de los
ángeles en primer lugar empezó su
discurso con un mensaje contundente a la
polémica que se ha generado alrededor de
la no asistencia de de la no invitación
de países como cuba venezuela y
nicaragua porque considera que no
cumplen con los estatutos que establecen
una democracia dijo la democracia está
bajo ataque entonces de esta manera se
refirió sin decir nombres directamente
de nadie a la polémica alrededor de la
no asistencia de los presidentes de
estos tres países pero dijo que
precisamente a través del diálogo es que
se resuelven las diferencias en un claro
llamado a estos tres líderes pero luego
se fue con los anuncios como lo decías
hizo importantes anuncios pero hay uno
que no se ha tenido tanto en cuenta en
general en la prensa que es el anuncio
de la alianza de las américas para la
prosperidad este se trataría invocando
el espíritu de la cumbre de 1994
inaugural también aquí en eeuu la
primera cumbre de las américas para en
la ciudad de miami en ese entonces se
quería crear un tratado de libre
comercio de las américas el presidente
yo bailé en invocando ese espíritu de
unión y anunció las negociaciones del
inicio de las negociaciones de la
alianza que te mencionó de las américas
para la prosperidad económica que tiene
tres puntos el primero es
incentivar la economía a través de la
inversión para controlar y crear más
empleo para que la evitar el flujo de
migrantes inicial norte del continente
el segundo punto de esto también es
incentivar la economía y el trabajo en
toda la región que es un problema que
también como sabemos genera migración
hacia el norte del continente y
finalmente atender la crisis climática
que la misma era genera migración hacia
el norte del continente principalmente
hacia eeuu entonces el plan del
presidente joe biden es un plan
ambicioso que tiene como objetivo
incentivar las economías de nuestros
países con el fin de controlar la
migración hacia el norte del continente
es muy importante decir que el
presidente del perú el pedro castillo
como anfitrión de la cumbre anterior que
tuvo lugar en lima hizo los mismos
anuncios que el presidente
estadounidense joe biden en español
natalie hablemos ahora de lo que se
espera para el día de hoy que para el
día de hoy que marcaría la agenda
bueno la jornada empieza con las
reuniones bilaterales entre varios de
los mandatarios el presidente
estadounidense y yo vaya en se reunirá
con él su homólogo de brasil jair
bolsonaro
se conocieron unos previos de las
discusiones que van a tener se espera
que el presidente estadounidense joe
biden le exprese su preocupación por la
seguridad en la amazonía un periodista
británico murió recientemente en la zona
entonces esta es una preocupación para
el presidente joe valdez al igual que
las elecciones del próximo mes de
octubre en brasil en las que el
presidente yair bolsonaro espera obtener
la red la reelección también continuarán
las reuniones bilaterales entre todos
los mandatarios que sí se encuentran
aquí presentes y en horas de la tarde va
a empezar la cada una de las
declaraciones en el centro de
convenciones de la ciudad de los ángeles
donde cada uno de los mandatarios aquí
presentes va a entregar su punto de
vista para sumar a esta declaración
final que se espera sea dada a conocer
este viernes